the greatest gladiator match in the
history of the world God versus man Son
of Krypton versus bat of Gotham mr. way
Clark Kent Daily Planet what's your
position on the bathroom ago ante in
Gotham Batman vs. Superman who will win
Batman there's a darkness to him in an
edge not now if you women like you I
don't think you've ever known a woman
like me I would put my money on Superman
because he's stronger panel 9
Batman vs Superman who will win if no
idea I can't wait to find out
Batman vs Superman who will win I say
Batman because Adam West has been on set
and I don't want him to take me out
and not just cuz he's my favorite but
because he's so smart he would
absolutely find a way to destroy
Superman it would just be that easy I'm
gonna say Batman because he derives his
power from the pain that he suffered
early in his life and that comes from a
very deep and personal place
I don't know much about these things
Henry Cavill is a really good friend of
mine so I gotta go was I want to say
Superman but you just know that Batman's
got things up his sleeve
we're really asking ourselves this
question again the only answer Superman
he is a bat and a man and he can draw
upon all his winged friends healthy
garden has technique and gadgets and I'm
offered out
that means great Superman is gonna kick
his ass I think I get into some trouble
if I didn't say Superman his family
Batman all the way sorry Superman he
looked great in tights but now
who will have no idea Superman my weapon
I think Batman would when my man
Superman Batman for the win Superman
Batman Batman Batman Batman will win
obviously Superman because Superman is
actually a superhero like a god I'm
gonna say that he's gonna have a leg up
in the situation my brother that's a
Superman who will win enough to watch
and find out
friendship is the real winner
I have a tendency to think in a certain
way
you